إنه وضع صعب للجميع
بشكل عام وخاصة أنا لأن
شيئًا مهمًا جدًا حدث
في هذا البلد وهو أننا فزنا
بكأس العالم بكل ما يعنيه ذلك بالنسبة
للاعبات كرة القدم وللجماهير،
وعلينا مناقشة هذه القضايا
شيئًا ما.  لم يسمع به أحد بالطبع، إنه
وضع ليس لطيفًا، لقد تحدث الكثير من الناس
علنًا ولم يعجبهم الوضع
وآمل أن يتم حل الوضع وألا
نضطر إلى مناقشة الأمر
بعد الآن، الشيء المهم هو أن
إسبانيا كانت مرة أخرى دولة  الفائز بكأس العالم في
كرة القدم ليس أمرًا سعيدًا أن
تناقشه،
أنت على حق تمامًا، لقد
كان الفوز بكأس العالم هائلاً، على الرغم من أن
هذه الحادثة طغت عليها لسوء الحظ
هذه الملحمة، أسألك مرة أخرى عن
مدى أهمية ذلك، فمن الواضح أنه
مهم بالنسبة لك.  تم توضيح
هذا الأمر، كيف يمكن
تصحيحه،
هل تعتقد أن لويس روبياليس بحاجة إلى
الاستقالة وأنه يجب أن يكون هناك إصلاح
شامل للإدارة في
كرة القدم الإسبانية في هذه المرحلة،
أعتقد أنه عندما تنشأ مثل هذه المواقف
التي ليست طبيعية ويكون لدينا
حجج و  هناك العديد من
الهيئات المختلفة التي يمكنها تقييم الوضع
وهذا هو الوضع الذي يعيشه
الاتحاد الإسباني الآن
سوف يستخلصون استنتاجاتهم الخاصة
والآراء الأخرى مجرد آراء وقد
يعتقد البعض أنها على حق وقد
يعتقد البعض أنها مخطئة ولكن  في الواقع
يتعين على الاتحاد الإسباني مناقشة الأمر،
ليس هناك الكثير مما يمكن إضافته ولكن
أعتقد أنه من المؤسف أن
الوضع كما ذكرت قد
طغى على حقيقة فوز إسبانيا، لقد
كنت صريحًا بشأن هذا وقد
وصفت هذه الملحمة بأكملها  باعتباره
ضررًا لصورة بلدك
واستخدام كرة القدم الإسبانية، لقد لعبت
كرة القدم في إسبانيا بنجاح كبير
لسنوات عديدة، وهذا يجب أن يكون مدمرًا بالنسبة
لك، ما مدى الضرر الذي تعتقد أن
هذا يمكن أن يلحقه بكرة القدم الإسبانية
بسمعتها من الآن فصاعدا؟
مواقف ممتعة لأي
شخص لا نحب أن
يحدث هذا لإسبانيا، لقد أضر
ببلدنا بهذا المعنى، كما ذكرت
قبل أن يتم تقييم هذه المواقف من قبل
الأشخاص المسؤولين، لكن
الرياضة الإسبانية وكرة القدم الإسبانية
فوق أي موقف.  يمكن لأي شخص أن
يسبب هذا الوضع لأنه كان من
الممكن السيطرة عليه والآن
يجب تقييمه. ما مدى قلقك من
إمكانية طرد الفرق الإسبانية
من المسابقات الأوروبية بما في ذلك
دوري أبطال أوروبا
والإضرار بفرص إسبانيا في
استضافة كأس العالم في عام 2030؟
لا أعتقد أن
إسبانيا ليست من ذلك النوع من البلدان حيث
يوصف هذا السلوك بأنه طبيعي،
فهناك مشكلات أخرى
حدثت في بلدان أخرى، وهذه
مواقف لم تحدث بشكل
منتظم